jacques baudrier conseiller pcf du 20e
arrondissement leur joie tout de suite
bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec mon sourire tu es france est-ce
qu'il faut reporter ce déconfinement qui
devrait être progressif en tout cas moi
je suis élu au conseil d'administration
d'ile-de-france mobilité qui est donc
d'autorité qui organise des transports
publics en ile de france et on est quand
même très inquiets des conditions avec
elle des usagers vont pouvoir être
transporté par les transports publics à
partir du 11 mai nous ce qu'on demande
c'est que en tout état de cause le
gouvernement assume le fait qu'il puisse
y avoir des millions de masques
chirurgicaux qu'il peut et distribué aux
entrées des gares et des stations de
métro délégué confinement et si on
n'obtient pas ce désengagement pour
avoir des masques chirurgicaux pour tous
les usagers et la distribution de gel
hydro un prix pas nous demanderons de
repousser le déconfinement jusqu'à temps
on essaie garantie pour les usa quelles
sont les informations qui équivaut par
diane est ce qu'on sera prêts selon vous
au 11 mai ce que les français vont
pouvoir bénéficier de masques et même de
tests d'ailleurs alors de deux masques
nous serons jamais des compétences et
les transports d'île de france 2 c'est
là où les deux tiers des transports
publics en france et en ile de france et
d'ailleurs un minimum deux à trois
millions de personnes qui risquent de
prendre les transports
on n'a aucune information aucune
garantie ok les annonces du président de
la république et pour l'instant nous on
n'a aucune garantie donc housse et ce
serait un drame de santé publique si les
usagers étaient transportés sans vers le
sans aucune protection
donc on demande d'avoir des garanties
pour l'instant nous n'avons aucune nous
allons demander vendredi conseil
d'administration du de france mobilité
qu'un voeu soit voté pour qui est un
engagement de l'ensemble des élus qui
siègent dans cette autorité pour
interpeller l'état pour dire nous on
rouvre pas les transports de dans des
conditions normales si on n'a pas ces
garanties pour les usagers ce que vous
pensez au niveau des transports que vous
devriez déjà
des informations qui laissent penser que
finalement tout le monde à votre niveau
en tout cas aura des masques
le problème c'est nous les contactons
d'un haut niveau de l'état
pour l'instant c'est comme pour les
écoles on a pris communiste l'éducation
nationale dit lendemain l'intervention
du président de la république
bon bah finalement ça sera peut-être
progressif peut-être parce certaines
écoles peut-être rien tout était flou
pour l'instant pour les transports
publics en ile de france qui sont un
lieu potentiel de contamination donc
c'est un problème de santé publique
majeur d pour des millions de gens on
n'a aucune garantie après on ne demande
qu'à les avoir si on nous dit que tout
le monde aura des masses on aura pour
installer des distributeurs de gel
hydroalcoolique partout très bien entre
elles pour l'instant on n'a aucune
information et donc nous c'est une
question de responsabilité en tant qu
élu communiste on se refuse à prendre un
risque de santé publique pareil voilà
pourquoi on intervient et le plus tôt
possible donc on a intervenu dès le
lendemain de l'intervention du président
la rue
si vous n'avez pas les moyens justement
pour protéger les usagers mais aussi
ceux qui travaillent dans les transports
en commun en ile de france
qu'est ce que vous allez faire nous ce
qu'on demande c'est la présente
l'ile-de-france aux unités c'est valérie
claisse le président de la région ont
consommé un voeu à son vote
vendredi on a des échanges avec lé
direction de de france mobilité plutôt
constructif d'ailleurs pour dire voilà
on y est hors de question de prendre ce
risque a priori non respect revient que
l'ensemble des élus de toutes
sensibilités confondues beauce eeb on
suit nos propositions de l'est
communiste en disant où on n'ouvre pas
le les transports à pleine capacité et
on se positionne contre 1 déconfinement
tant qu'on n'a pas les garanties
après voilà est il ce qu'on demande
c'est qu'il y ait un conseil
d'administration extraordinaire de
france mobilité ou l'état le préfet de
région mais invisible sentais pas des
responsables des responsables du
gouvernement un niveau important vienne
s'engage
devant nous et répondre aux questions de
tous les élus tous hommes mais aussi des
associations d'usagers des transports
publics et des syndicalistes des
représentants des salariés de la sncf la
ratp les entreprises de bustes
d'empereurs pour que chacun tout le
monde et des garanties et tout le monde
puisse s'exprimer
qui est que l'information soit pleine et
entière à n'importe que les usagers
puissent être assurées merci beaucoup
jacques baudrier pour être intervenu en
direct sur arte france je rappelle que
vous êtes le conseiller pcf du 20e
arrondissement de paris merci à vous